Welcome to 15.071x,
The Analytics Edge.
In this first lecture, we'll
discuss how analytics redefines
the meaning of intelligence,
how it can contribute
to your personal
happiness and health.
Data is transforming
business, social interactions,
and the future of our society.
The amount of electronic data
that exists in the world today
is a phenomenal 2.7
zettabytes, which
is equal to the storage
required for more than 200
billion high-definition movies.
Not only the amount of
data is extremely high,
but it increases at
exponential rates.
Our ability to effectively
process this data
is also increasing very rapidly.
As an example, decoding
the human genome
originally took 10
years to process.
Now it can be achieved
in just one week.
Analytics is increasingly
important in the world today,
and this influence is
expected to increase.
McKinsey estimates that
there is a shortage
of 140,000 to 190,000 people
with deep analytical skills
to fill the demand of jobs
in the United States by 2018.
IBM has changed its business
focus over the last 100 years
very successfully from
typewriters to mainframes
to personal computers
to consulting, and now
to analytics.
It has invested over
$20 billion since 2005
to grow its analytics business.
Companies will invest
more than $120 billion
by 2015 on analytics, hardware,
software, and services.
Analytics is becoming
increasingly critical
in almost every industry,
from health care,
to media, to sports, to finance,
to government, and many others.
Let us give a
definition of analytics
so we make it as
concrete as possible.
We define analytics to be
the science of using data
to build models that lead
to better decisions, that
add value to individuals, to
companies, to institutions.
Note that there are four
ingredients-- data, models,
decisions, and value.
And all four are needed
in this definition.
What are the key
messages of this class?
First, analytics provides
a competitive edge
to individuals and companies.
Analytics are often critical
to the success of a company.
And they provide often the
decisive essential technology.
Our teaching methodology is to
teach you analytics techniques
through real-world
examples and real data.
And our overarching goal is to
convince you of the analytics
edge and inspire
you to use analytics
in your career and your life.
The teaching team comes
from the Operations Research
Center at MIT and the
Sloan School of Management.
I am Dimitris Bertsimas.
I have received my Ph.D.
from MIT from 1985 to 1988.
And I have been
with the MIT faculty
at the Sloan School of
Management since 1988.
Currently, I'm the co-director
of the Operations Research
Center.
My career is centered
in analytics.
And I believe that analytics
can change the world.
The other instructor of this
class is Allison O'Hair.
Allison received her Ph.D. from
the Operations Research Center
at MIT in 2013.
Allison and I have
worked together
in the area of health
care analytics,
and are working at the moment
with our colleague Bill
Pulleyblank on an
analytics textbook.
The teaching
assistants in the class
are Iain Dunning, Angie King,
Velibor Misic, John Silberholz,
and Nataly Youssef, all Ph.D.
students at the Operations
Research Center at MIT.
To give you a sense of the
breadth of applications
in this class, we'll
cover the story
of IBM Watson, the computer
that beat the best human players
in Jeopardy!, the company
eHarmony, the Framingham Heart
Study, and D2Hawkeye,
a company that I have
been involved for
almost a decade.
Other examples include
the story of Moneyball,
how analytics can help predict
the Supreme Court decisions,
the role analytics have
played in predicting
the outcomes of the US
presidential elections, how
analytics can utilize
effectively data from Twitter,
Netflix, airline revenue
management, radiation
therapy, sports scheduling,
and many others.